we'll be talking with professor mary
beard about her new book 12 caesars as
hannah showed you images of power from
the ancient world to the modern which
you can see here is this extremely
handsome hardback book filled with
really beautiful color images i'm going
to
show you some
if you can see that on the camera um and
it's also as it happens brilliantly
written by mary the most knowledgeable
and accessible guide you could hope for
through the roman world
mary beard as i imagine many of you
already know is one of the world's
leading classicists and cultural
commentators she's a specialist in roman
history and art professor of classics at
the university of cambridge and the
author of best-selling and award-winning
books including
spqr a history of ancient rome and women
in power and manifesto she's also known
to many of us as a familiar trusted and
beloved tv presenter from civilizations
meet the romans the shock of the nude
and inside culture with mary bid which
is just back on air now we should say
before we get started
talking about mary's new book 12 seasons
let me tell you um that tonight's event
will run for an hour and for the first
part of it the first 30 minutes i'm
going to be in conversation with mary
and then for the second half we'll hand
over to you to take your questions you
can actually start asking those
questions now by clicking on the ask
question button under the video screen
and typing in your question there and if
you want your name to be mentioned
please type it in the box and do
remember to press send you can also
tweet along to our conversation and many
of you who follow mary on twitter will
know that she's an ardent tweeter and a
conscientious responder to tweets um i'm
not making promises
you can also tweet a long time
conversation using the hashtag
iq2 and as a note please keep your slide
tabs open because we're going to be
showing you a series of wonderful images
from mary's book and although it's
lovely to look at us um you might also
want to look at the images too now mary
can we can we start at the beginning
with the title of the book just in case
some of us are not classicists and won't
be entirely sure what that refers to
this is a very particular group of roman
emperors isn't it why these guys for
this book yeah the 12 caesars are the
first 12 roman emperors or almost
emperors they they run from julius
caesar who is assassinated in 44 bc
to the emperor domitian who is
assassinated in 96 a.d
and
they became famous and they are the sort
of in a way the kind of type roman
emperors
because their lives were recorded
in a series of biographies by roman
writers suetonius who did them who did a
biography of each one of them one by one
so they they became a group now they
were never actually really a group in
the ancient world itself
but
by the time you get to the renaissance
and with the rediscovery of writing by
people serotonins and others um somehow
they they come to stand for roman power
they're not the only roman emperors you
know there's hadrian later and marcus
aurelius dead famous but this lot
kind of
take a
take a kind of pole position in
what roman emperors are some of them we
don't any longer know much about
but they
they they are the guys who get
represented lineups paintings and
sculptures done in the modern era
and and we're starting our conversation
with with a couple of ancient busts of
everyone everyone's darling julius
caesar
perhaps the most famous caesar um
tell us about them
well i wanted to show people this
because i just wanted to kind of remind
us all what uh
what a roman emperor even if caesar is
kind of half an emperor julius caesar
almost an emperor now what does a roman
emperor look like and um
and i think that
for me these two
guys
um one on the left recently found in all
the other
uh probably a fake actually
from the british museum
um they sort of sum up what
what the face of roman power looks like
and actually to be let's be honest
i think
we see these guys on museum shelves on
gallery walls etc and we sort of nodded
them you know we think right okay
you know roman bigwig on we go
and
one of the things that the book tries to
do is to say look actually there's
something much more interesting and edgy
about these images
than the way we usually take them which
is you know even i go into you know i've
spent my life studying these blokes and
i go into a museum and i see a lineup of
the 12 caesars and i think oh 12 caesars
right and
i i was sort of wanting to
kind of destabilize that a bit and to
say look we can make them more
interesting than this
but this too is a
this pair are very interesting because
as i said the one on the right
is thought to be a fake
um the one on the left is
just rediscovered you know in the last
20 years from the river roan in all you
know and neither actually do we really
know
was or was meant to be julius caesar
because most of these ancient busts of
empress come down to us not absolutely
all but 99
come down without any name attached to
them
and so there's a big guessing game which
has changed throughout the centuries of
who actually is who and you know you go
into a museum and you see a very
confident label you know the emperor
titus and you think first of all who the
hell is he
but then you ought to think how the hell
do they know
and of course we don't really there's a
kind of
you know there's a bit of a sort of fuzz
over
who really is who and most of them are
actually identified
because we try to match up the images on
their coins
with the images in their sculpture but
you know you try matching up a you know
as a coin with an image you're saying to
me to hide with one of these guys you
know and it's
anyone's guess honestly yeah
but why is it that i i think that this
is julius caesar what are the
distinguishing
qualities or characteristics of the
person that we think is caesar
in this case
there's been most debate about the one
on the left
that on caesar's coins
um
he said he he's shown with a with a
really wrinkled neck
yeah
so you find a guy with a really wrinkled
neck you think yep
it's caesar now actually there's quite a
lot of people in the ancient world who
have really wrinkled necks but we're so
concerned to kind of
focus in on caesar
and and the other thing that we do is we
go to
the description of caesar
in seretonius uh the only real
description in the biography and we try
to match that up too
and
but it's terribly terribly fragile you
know the the
the very keen on the kind of
sunken cheeks
um and so the right hand man looks kind
of quite plausible but the sunken cheeks
you know the latin is a bit difficult to
interpret you know that's it so you know
and the other thing that comes out and
the coins is a prominent adam's apple so
they look at these and they say uh-huh
well i can't really see a prominent
adam's apple in either of these so it is
a mix and match and i think
the important thing for us to realize
now is that
i mean i think we often imagine
that modern science or you know modern
studies of
ancient portraiture will make it easier
we're better at identifying these guys
than people were in let's say the 17th
or the 18th century
we know better we're probably more
gullible than people in the past were
um you know
the great art historian winkelmann
thought that you'd never be able really
to find
um a real authentic julius caesar
because all you're doing is kind of
matching things up
to
coins and to your sort of assumption
um about what an emperor looks like you
know so that you know my assumption i
have to say let's be honest is built on
you know kenneth williams in carry on
clio
plus a bit of asterix kind of
uh shoved in yeah and
you know and
i'm always trying to refine that in
ancient sculptures and that's what
people were doing in the 16th century
and the 18th century and so on i i i
confess to being a
an asterisk reader and having my
dominant sense of caesar is from the
asterix graphic novels of the comics um
but what you're describing is like a
kind of classical game of guess who
right what do they have it is wrinkles
on the neck and is is that gb caesar
we were just talking about asterix and
you were talking about kenneth williams
maybe i'll we can
talk about the next images because part
of the argument of your book is how the
the roman images of various caesars
endure how they become a shorthand for
power
how
they become instantly recognizable even
if they're not exactly caesar and
they're imitated inappropriate well into
the modern period
tell us about this yeah well i think
that's absolutely right and i think that
although i've been you know a bit
gleaming skeptical and a bit of a downer
so far about saying look we can't you
know let's go back to these ancient
busts you know it's very perilous really
to put name on them
i think what's interesting is that
uh alongside that
you
you do get a kind of sense even among
people who say oh i know nothing about
what roman emperors look like they do
because they recognize them in all kinds
of places in a standardized image which
in a way looks a bit back to ancient
world it's not entirely uh unrelated
but has kind of picked up all this
baggage from the centuries in between so
i think on the left you know it doesn't
take
a lot
for people to spot that that is nero
fiddling while rome burned you know
because you know how many politicians
have we seen you know dressed up with a
bit of a laurel wreath a bit of a toke
playing something which is almost a liar
and there's flames in the background and
it says this guy hasn't got his mind on
the job
um and that's gordon brown for you but
you know you could do it with trump you
could do with g w bush um you know it is
still the
uh a a kind of classic meme really yeah
being attentive politician
and
on the right i mean i'm afraid i just
like quite like to see augustus
advertising a beer being having a beer
named after him in my local brewery you
know
what's not to like well those of us who
don't know augustus what would what what
does that say about milton brewery and
their bit no advertising here of course
mary but what
does it say
does it
appear to be named after augustus i have
to say that milton brewery no
advertising whatsoever um i've got a
whole series of imperial beers
because they have found
a lot a lot of people have i think of a
sense that you know even if we don't
know much about them even if we're
you know we've got this
this uh you know very perilous grasp not
only on what they look like but on what
they did yeah nevertheless
there's still something characterful you
know so you can have the sedate but
powerful beer you know which is augustus
you can have that nasty little beer
which is nero you could have the really
naughty one which is caligula
brilliant i think i know which one i
want um you've already started talking
about nero let's narrow in on a little
bit more on him what do we learn from
these representations of nero what do we
have here
well i think nero is very interesting in
terms of his later reception um he was
demonized in antiquity
um
we had no idea whether he was a real
baddie or a part baddie or a part goodie
but by the time
there'd been a rebellion against him his
posthumous rep reputation became
as a monster
but
i think that what's very interesting is
that
later ages you know actually from the
medieval period
really up to
the mid 20th century
they find nero
because of the specific crimes that he
was supposed to have committed a
wonderful
kind of focus
of um
of discussion and debate about
corruption about lust and so forth
because
nero
was a boy emperor
uh was uh
to believe the standard stories he was
eased onto the throne
by his mom agrippina who had married um
the emperor claudius
um
the rumors were that he'd had a
necessity was an incestuous affair with
mum
and that pretty soon after he takes the
throne
he decides he has to get rid of her and
he has her killed
and
uh
one ancient story is that after
after the death he stands in the hit
squad and after the death
he
he goes along and he inspects the corpse
um and he inspects the corpse as a lover
or here
in a sort of more gory medieval version
as a dissector and he's a dissector
uh a
what is he after
he wants to know
not only about his passion for agrippina
his own passion he wants to know where
he came from
uh so
there are ancient texts which say
agrippina said when she was being killed
strike me in my womb strike my belly in
a and
we have a story here
which resonates you know both in the
15th century and the 19th century
of the idea of the emperor and
succession from his mother
but combined with
an extraordinary kind of sadism
but but also as you can see
when when we get to waterhouse um
combined with you know this this attempt
to think okay so what does it feel like
to be the young emperor
and here everybody looks at this
this image of nero the remorse of nero
after the murder of his mother and they
think blimey you know that's a moody
teenager you know
we've seen those guys you know sitting
on their beds not getting up and
listening to you know my day it was
leonard cohen but it's not
now i'm sure different um but there is a
sense that nero was a moody teenager
and here i mean i think this is in some
ways one of my
favorite
or you know favorite images to hate of
nero
because it's uh the image of the dead
nero there's a rebellion against him in
68 he kills himself
he finds it very hard to kill himself
um
uh he so he has to be helped to put the
dagger in but the only people who are
left
um
are his uh
faithful female servants
who take this still young emperor
away to burial and very interestingly if
you ever go
it's on for another month or so in the
british museum
in the current nero exhibition they
actually have the gravestone of one of
these women who took him away to burial
but the clever smirnoff is clever artist
and in the corner is a really horrible
little sculpture hellenistic perhaps
second century bc
sculpture of a boy strangling a goose
and you perhaps don't notice it first
it's a there's many copies of this it's
quite famous
uh hellenistic second century statue and
menopause put this in i think
very very much to comment on nero you
know there is this toddler
playing with
strangling
killing
his pet his pet goose and you say why is
it there
well i think it's there because this
artist is trying to say what does
tyranny consist in
you know here's the dead tyrant
but is the dead tyrant really like a
child
who
doesn't quite know what he's doing you
know
is every tyrant like a toddler who kills
his pet yeah yeah
yes i think is the answer to that i mean
i think that's one of the great gifts of
this book is having
you
attend to those details and to be able
to decipher them and understand them in
context and to to cast the painting in a
different slant and i should say this
image in the book is on a double page
spread so it's especially imposing and
and very beautiful and to be clear the
images of the twelve caesars take
different forms
so we're not only thinking about busts
and paintings but also tapestries like
the one we're about to see depicting the
assassination of of caesar
do you want to tell me about this one
well
this is extremely interesting and again
i think a lot of the images that i put
in the book well some of them are dead
famous you know they're
you know memorings portraits and so
forth but but many of them
are things that most of us me included
walk past and i think tapestries
are one things that we know we've we
really haven't got our eye into
tapestries any longer
and
this is this is really important and
it's on display in the vatican and
barely looked at actually in a gallery
of tapestries
and
it is
the assassination of caesar 16th century
tapestry
what for me that was very interesting
is that it is
a pear
and another version of
um
a set of tapestries that henry viii
commissioned for hampton court palace
also
in the mid 15th 16th century
and
those tapestries have long gone they've
you know they presumably ended up
probably in a royal skip somewhere in
the late 19th century
but the second as we know from
inventories the second most valuable
work of art
in hampton court in the whole of the
royal collection
was a set of tapestries
which featured
uh julius caesar
in his conflicts with his enemies uh
particularly the enemy of the civil wars
pompey and it ended with
uh
a terribly famous scene um
made more famous by ju by um
shakespeare's julius caesar of course of
the assassination of caesar and you
think look these things are getting
everywhere these
these images of roman power
um and the opposition to roman power
you know are everywhere and now henry
viii's prized possessions
were a series of tapestries which ended
in the assassination of the monarch
and you know one of the questions i ask
is how do we deal with that you know
this this is not a glorification of
monarchy and a lot of these images
are not glorification
they are questioning about the nature of
our i think
this is a jean leon jerome but it tells
a different story to the tapestry is
that right it's a wonderfully different
story because in the tapestries and the
one we've just seen i mean at the moment
of assassination caesar is still the
center of attention
um and
he's the star of the show he's being
murdered as a star of the show um
jerome here in the mid-19th century i
mean you can barely spot
in the bottom left-hand corner you know
the bundle of rags which is the body of
caesar and everything the whole kind of
interest
in in this picture is what's going to
happen next you know there's the
conspirators they've got bright white
togas and they're lifting their daggers
up uh and
i think this is a rather kind of
uncomfortable image
certainly for anybody interested in
monarchy which is because it's saying
look caesar's gone there you know as
soon as you're killed
you're a monarch you're dead you're
assassinated you're no one
you know and everybody is now thinking
about what happens next and you know
monarchy and imperial power is
evanescent jerome reminds us
let's talk about i mean that's a very
important thing for lots of readers for
lots of people in power to remember i
think but
i want us to talk about women and power
to cite your your last brilliant book
there are no empresses but there are
wives and daughters and mothers who
often have
important if ancillary roles in these
stories of the caesars how are they
depicted i think i think we're starting
with the infamous messelina who's a bit
of a favorite of mine
yes
messalina is another wife of claudius
before nearest mom agrippina
and
messalina
mussolina's reputation within latin
literature is of uh lust godmat you know
she's she is reputed to have challenged
the prostitutes of rome to a contest
about who could sleep with the most men
in a single night and messalina wins
i think what's really interesting about
this and i
you know in some ways it's it i i did
try very hard in this book
to say um
look
this is actually a very roman power is
very male but you can't you know you've
got to look at the women too
uh uh one of the things you find is that
there are hugely kind of lurid tales
about
the wives of emperor of emperors there's
no official role as you say for an
empress but there are nuri tales about
the wives of emperors and all clear
worries about what the power of the wife
of the emperor is and in ancient
sculpture if we identify them correctly
and it's the same problem as with um
emperors so probably bigger um
one of the things that ancient sculpture
sort of
commissioned by the emperor does is to
say
empresses
the wife of the emperor is always the
mother of the air you know that is the
role she is absolutely perfect so you
have these fekund mothers in roman art
matched by or contrasted with
um these stories
of the danger of these women who were
always liable to get out to pollute the
um the
the bloodline right and you know what we
saw before was uh the way um artists in
19th and 20th century picked that up and
so beardsley you know
he's much more interested in
messaline at the hall than mesolina the
mother
uh and he is
here's a another i mean i think very
unsettling you know sadistic
image because of the death of masolina
because in the end
these women
get
eliminated
and
uh there is a you know we've seen
agrippina being eliminated and there's
rather you know horribly medieval
prurient all
19th century prurient images of the dead
body
here is
uh
messalina actually being um annihilated
by claudius's hit squad and what's
interesting is that the woman in the
foreground he's not looking is
messalina's mom
messalina's mother is there at the
murder and she can't better look at it
and i mean what i'm hoping that people
get out of the book is that you know
again i think that kind of picture you
look at it and you think what's going on
here you know
something roman
but if you dig into if you dig under the
surface um
you see that there are really quite
important and unsettling issues
being talked about this is domestic
violence actually
yeah yeah
there are there are moments in the book
i i should say that it's you know a
deeply scholarly
and engaging book and but and you don't
succumb to the temptation to be um
presentist to insist that we read those
images in our own context but there are
tantalizing moments where you mention
particular people and in fact in in this
in the section about women you you talk
about ivanka trump and meghan markle and
the way that
our political journalism political
critique and commentary turn to the
wives and the mothers and the daughters
at particular moments when they want to
say particularly things about about
leaders yes you know what
we use women as an explanatory tool
to explain you know to explain the
actions of men in power and
you know
sean phillips says olivia in the bbc's i
claudius is one absolutely classic
example of that and it comes directly
from ancient writers too but we're doing
it we're still doing it we did it with
sherry blair we're doing it we're doing
it with carrie johnson you know yeah you
know who chose the wallpaper well it's
got to be carrie um yeah
yeah yeah
they have a role too the one of the the
the intriguing questions of the book is
the way that the the faces of the
emperors and and their wives are not
just of their own time they re resurface
eerily throughout the long history
of about tell me about that yeah well i
mean i think one of the interesting
things as you say is that it's not just
that we're dealing with
um
modern images of the empress messalina
or whatever we're dealing with the faces
these faces the famous faces of roman
power being copied and re-used in
completely different contexts and here's
a very nice one because on the right um
you've got a roman statue from the
capitoline museum in rome um always
thought to be until the middle of the
last century um the image of agrippina
um whether that was um nero's mum
or nero's granny they were both called
agrippina
and when carnival
was
commissioned to sculpt
uh napoleon's mother
what does he do
he
takes that image which he believed to be
agropina
uh and
reuses it
to
represent the mother of napoleon and you
think
so was that innocent was that entirely
innocent well some people would say well
he probably meant it to be the good
agropina you know
that is the older one nero's granny um
rather than the bad agrippina nero's mum
and lover right
and yet you say
so
what were the sons of either agrippina
well
agrippina the elder the good agropina
who this might possibly have been very
unlikely um her son was caligula
the son of the younger agropina that was
nero
so when you do napoleon's mom
looking like
this so-called agrippina what you're
saying about napoleon yeah
is he is he caligula is he nero what a
bloody awful choice
but i suppose in some ways my favorite
example and this is one i think which is
sort of
really dropped out of popular
consciousness i mean
250 years ago everybody watching this
lecture
uh this chat would have recognized this
sculpture it's now
not recognizable by even specialists in
in students of roman art
and it was a sculpture
that was
dug up in rome in the renaissance
and was believed to be
almost 100 certainly wrongly
the emperor vitellius
one of the short-lived successes of the
emperor nero a truly nasty piece of work
if you believe ancient sources um a
glutton he's got a treble chin
a sadist um
eventually horribly put to death by the
guy who comes after him you know he
had a sort of reign of terror for about
three months in 69
but people saw this and they matched it
up in this
standard way thought that looks like the
images of vitellius on his coins
but
it became
absolutely
uh
unmissable image
that face it was a recognizable face
uh it was a vitalius and
uh
but it was more than that it was a kind
of template
of a physionomy
and what you've got on this side now
is
veronese's
later 16th century
um feast in the house of levi uh
originally it had been designed as a
last supper as a complicated story
but the uh the image i want you to look
at is the one at the beginning
the foreground
and
what you have there
is what veronese described in his
discussion of this painting as the
carver you know he's the guy who's going
to come and carve the meat and
the face is vitellius the face is
the vitellius that was in venice at the
same time as you come to venice and so
varanasi is using
that
as we now know wrongly identified face
of vitellius
to give an image to this carver
and
what i think for me is very interesting
is that i think there's something
knowing about that
that
this guy
is a servant who cuts the meat
in suetonius's tradition about the
vitellius
of the model
italias is the emperor who is actually
the glutton the consumer so
so what veronese is doing is kind of
swapping around the roles and meanwhile
this vitalius is looking directly across
at jesus in the center of the table
and so you have the worst roman emperor
you can kind of think of you know
actually pre you know leaves
nero and caligula looking like pussycats
he is it's a conversion painting
yeah but it's a conversion painting
which is foregrounding
someone who we have to see
as a roman emperor
yeah do you think veronese's audience
would have recognized vitelius there
they would have been more literate than
perhaps lots of us are right now i think
in those places
i mean look
we have to be careful about kind of
assuming that everybody everybody in the
16th 17th century knew all these things
and we don't i mean there was loads of
people who didn't and they made messes
and misidentified but that sculpture of
vitalius which had been actually left to
the city of venice was
absolutely
the yeah the the
the classic
uh
you know
tourist
image of roman sculpture that the city
of venice had you know you could not
have been in venice and not known that
guy yeah yeah that's amazing to to see
it through your eyes like that
but also to understand the painting
uh in that quite subtle context as well
what's this this is
know here we are in the middle of the
19th century oh my goodness me there's
vitellius coming up again
because uh if you look towards the left
and i haven't got a detail of this i'm
afraid but you can see a lot rather
lovely odelisk with a naked back very
highlighted um on the left-hand side of
the painting and there's a slumbering
figure in front of her
who's actually gone to sleep you know
he's so out of it in this obvious
banquet of roman decadence right he has
gone to sleep
um so much he doesn't even spot that
there's a naked woman in front
if you go up close and you look at him
he's vitellius really same vitellius
from venice again and you know my i can
pretty well give you a pledge if you go
around any major art gallery with the
picture of that sculpture of vitellius
in your hand you will find at least one
painting between the 16th and the 19th
century which reproduces him
well
but the last few slides we're going to
look at are
are about what you've been telling us
the ubiquity of these emperors um and
one of the things we realize in the
course of the book is how adept you mary
are at spotting this spotting them
everywhere tell us how and why why these
images of the emperor's resurface
i i think they
they partly resurface but they partly
never go away
and i think they don't go away even now
although you know we live in it we live
in a myth that we haven't really kind of
you know we've we've forgotten all this
ancient history we haven't really
and here is
you know we put this in because edmonia
lewis was
really the first professional
african-american
female sculptor in the united states
uh and she has a a story which is marked
by terrible racist abuse
um but she goes off to rome and she
actually leaves america and she sets up
um shop in rome to great success but
what's she doing she is actually making
replicas for the partly for the tourist
trade
of here um called the young octavian on
the left is her version of it it's a
copy of
the person we would now call the young
emperor augustus um
uh with uh an image from the vatican on
the right
and you know again it's interesting we
now
none of these identifications are clear
and so of course we now don't actually
think that this young octavian on the
right really was the young octavian that
would never mind she did and so she's
producing
um that sense of
you know i can replicate
in the late 19th century
um the image of
this roman emperor of the first
century and she also does as we can see
in the next slide
um
something much more adventurous
which is a statue that she does of
cleopatra
and
i think the previous slide was you know
i think pretty insipid actually
this is you know there is nothing
insipid about this
interestingly she's doing
this big portrait of the dying cleopatra
at exactly the same time
as she's doing the portrait of the young
octavian that we've just seen or the
young augustus and you say
is there a connection here
well yes there is because it's
that
young boy
who forces this noble queen to suicide
yeah wow she's put she's putting this
together she in a much more interesting
way than people i think often realize
i mean i i think we just have a few end
pictures just to remind us that this
hasn't gone away you know you know i
think people might well say well look um
we don't engage with roman emperors or
empresses anymore well
artists are still engaging with them all
the time he's you know a whole
array
particularly like the uh the turkish
artist chocolate emperor which is
another version of augustus but we have
just seen vitalius
uh both in an ancient marble version so
called um and in varanasi and in couture
and he is very end of the 19th century
medado rosso
he's taking the same
image
um and he's
and he's kind of saying look this is a
blob of flesh this is a sort of this is
an uncontrolled
blob or flesh
and it's in the dna and sadly i would
say it's not on display oh i think i
would recognize vitellius anywhere now
he looks like a walrus i've i've learned
from you mary i've spotted him at 50
places yeah and you you can tell you i
tell you you find him there's there's
jim dine doing it again
you can find one of the best things you
know if you
going around european and uh um american
art galleries is spot the vitellius and
you'll find
dozens and dozens of them and that is an
image that we've forgotten in a way when
it isn't a recognizable image to us but
i think if you see it and recognize that
and you know a little bit bit about the
history of vitellius it makes those
paintings all those sculptures speak
differently to you i think it adds
something and
you can't see that here actually the
emperor in the books in
jerome's um
gladiatorial scene is actually also
vitalius if you got up very close
but what's great about this is it shows
the connection between this and modern
film
because uh when ridley scott was um
planning the gladiatorial scenes in uh
gladiator for the movie gladiator he
goes back
to jerome his painting of the death of
caesar that we saw we've just seen his
amphitheatrical painting with vitalius
in the books
uh
it is that
as ridley scott explicitly said
that he's recreating in his movie so
it's utterly embedded in modern culture
and popular culture yeah and that image
is instantly recognizable too uh this is
the moment we turn to our audience mary
we've delayed for so long chatting away
that they have been very prolific
they've been submitting
so many interesting and learned
questions so i'm going to try and work
through them but i'm also going to
remind anybody who hasn't yet asked
their question that they can do so by
clicking on the ask question button
under the video screen where you can
type in your question and if you would
like me to mention your name then do add
it to your question and remember to
press send
and you can tweet along if you haven't
already using the hashtag iq2
so the first question i'm excited mary
is
i think
this is a
this question gets to the crux of things
and i think you're going to have an
answer to it and this is from stella
what did the romans do with the statues
of rulers they no longer admired and
what can we learn from them yes
i think that the romans rather more
imaginative than we are you know um
uh
some of them they chucked in the river
you know there was the constant
treatment for some of us and i think
there's always been that for
for figures of power that we no longer
admire but i think one of the
the cleverest tricks the romans had
on marble
sculpture be more difficult on bronze
is they got a statue of an emperor who'd
who'd fallen very much from favor um and
it had been an expensive work of art for
let's say our local town to to
commission so what do they do
um they get their chisels out
and they change the features of the
hated emperor into the features of the
one they now like
um and it doesn't cost very much he's
altered and hey presto
um sculptures have moved on and i think
that
for the romans and i think also up to
quite a way into the modern world
sculptors sculptures were seen very much
as works in progress we have a very
fixed view of sculptures you know that
you know they don't move and they're
always the same and they're you know and
and therefore we have a really big
problem about what to do with them
um
the romans were a bit more laid back
about it and they thought well there's
again in the
current british museum exhibition
um
you can see uh
what clearly was a statue of nero which
has been yeah neatly neatly retooled to
be a statue of vespasian wow so i mean
we we can't encourage people or can we
encourage people to go be tall statues
but it's it's a
magical idea but not so radical to think
that our statues might not be so fixed
that we don't have to they don't have to
be
um
in place forever no and also you know
sometimes with at least with gods and
goddesses i'm not sure if you can show
this with figures of humans in power
they just put a new label on it yeah you
know just says no this is not diana it's
somebody else
you know and i i think they
they were just a little less hyde-bound
about the fixity the structure is the
way yeah yeah yeah that is a different
attitude isn't it um there's a question
from stuart etherington um about the
very british museum exhibition you just
mentioned um he suggested that it gives
a revisionist view of nero do you agree
with this interpretation
um
the answer that is yes and no
and i think it's certainly been re
interpreted the exhibition has been
interpreted
um as saying that
and i can see why
that um nero was not a baddie after all
but quite a goodie
i i think for me what i would say is
that
what it's revealing to me
is how
these images of emperors were formed
by usually by their successors you know
if you are assassinated in rome you get
turned into a monster you know you might
have been a monster
but you might not have been but
as soon as the next regime comes along
you get an enormous propaganda campaign
and i think for me what the the british
museum exhibition does
is to show us how perilous our judgment
is on these people that it's dependent
on
on on the inch well you know history is
the you know they always the history of
the winners you know
nero
nero has a character assassination
by the guys who come next
and you know whether whether that means
he was a goodie
who knows i think in a sense that
judgment is probably lost to us
yeah there's a there's a a a quite
intriguing question from festus
brackets a nice roman name they say
i i know my question is out of the scope
of this current discussion but were
there any african emperors p.s i'm a
massive fan of mary beard i could just
respond to the last bit if you prefer
mary
um well
the the very end of the the second
beginning of the third century there's
um
the um perception is severus
comes from libya in north africa um
and
so he he absolutely undoubtedly
counts his home as africa
what the color of his skin was and what
his ethnicity was is being deeply
debated
he certainly has some
biological relationship with posh
italians
but he's also part of a north african
community and almost certainly um
was
counted himself in some ways
um
as having an african identity yeah um so
you know yes there were and he was
you know he was succeeded by syrians and
one of the most extraordinary
things about the roman empire which you
know in some ways he's you know horribly
unadmirable um and you know brutal and
nasty and don't ever want to go back
there
but
one of the things that is very clear
about how the
um
the
the power structure works is that rome
is
incorporating
people at the very top of the hierarchy
from all over its empire from syria to
spain to africa
they all represent themselves as looking
the same
right yeah so there's a there's a real
puzzle there yeah and a great question
that listens to such an interesting
answer um a question from norbert and i
think this is a nice question which
public figure would you most like to see
commemorated by a statue
oh blimey
i mean it's hard you know because my
normal answer to questions like that is
that you know please can we actually
um widen widen the kind of um the
category of who we who we put statues up
to
you know and you know i think you know
you know what please can we have some
ordinary people that we have statues um
so he's a public figure um
uh
i think i've got you know i i think i've
got to go for a woman you know there
there is still a
there is still a gender deficit you know
never mind
you know an ethnicity racial deficit in
our public statutes there's still a a
gender deficit
you know and i
you know i think back to my childhood
and i'm sure there is a statue of the
person i'm going to name but
i just remember you know barbara castle
being a
you know a as a whirlwind
and you know clearly was you know you
know i look back now she was never going
to you know you know why couldn't she
have become prime minister she might
have been bloody good yeah so i'd quite
like you know i quite like a statue of
barbara castle someone will now write in
instantly and tell me that there is one
but
i will have her but also you know one of
the
i think one of the implicit thoughts in
your book is that a cultural memory
lasts because of these works and so
why not keep a cultural memory someone
alive in a general collective cultural
memory like barbara castle yeah i think
i think that's true but also i think
that um i think what the book shows is
that the people that that are in the
public sphere for centuries have not
just been people we admired you know
when we put up statues to the 12 caesars
you know bust the 12 seizes in the 18th
century the people commissioning those
busts knew they were a load of bastards
they weren't just putting them up
because they were admirable they were in
some ways putting them up in order to
have a debate with them about what power
was
yes
um there there was a this i'm not
suggesting that this is related to the
your last remark but there was a
question asking which roman emperor in
your view most closely resembles our
illustrious prime minister
oh it's always terribly terribly
terribly difficult to that and i have to
say that over the last um sort of 15
years or so the commonest question i've
been asked
um by
by inquiries but also by journalists
looking for a story is which emperor
does then you know donald trump you know
you you name
most resemble and i have to say that
i've come down to
um
uh the same answer for every single one
which is the emperor eligabilis the
beginning of the third century a.d and i
say this because no one knows a blind
thing about him
and i think so i always say the emperor
ella gables because
i i then believe that um the person to
whom i've given the answer we'll go and
find out some extremely interesting
things about this early third century
roman emperor so just try wiki on ella
gabilis
and of course you'll have a great time
and what that amazing lawrence uh
almatydima painting which you mentioned
in the book yes i mean just to give
people a little hint about what they
might find about ella gabalus
is that um according to a
truly unreliable biography of him um
really truly unreliable
one of his tricks was that
he
invited people to dinner and
showered them with rose petals so many
rose petals that they smothered and died
and there is a wonderful 19th century
alma tadama painting which shows
um the dinner party of ella gabilis with
the poor guests being smothered
under rose petals which just goes to
show that when the emperor is generous
to you he's jolly dangerous
absolutely
i i once saw that painting at um layton
house and it was um
sponsored by a very famous fancy candle
company and i wondered whether they
understood the
disconnect between the rose petals and
the image and my candles but still i i
guess i i wonder ella gables is also
reputed to have invented the whoopee
cushion
invited people to dinner um and when he
wasn't smothering them with rose petals
don't believe it don't believe a word of
this by the way um he's also put them on
inflatable cushions which he had the
enslaved people um remove the cork from
and so they all ended up on the floor
with the cushion deflated wow
i think that is worth a a search on
wikipedia
there is um a very learned question here
about montana's the trance of the
caesars but if there is anybody to
answer this question it's you mary bird
so great conversation what are your
thoughts on montana's the trans the
tramps of the caesars why do you think
oliver cromwell kept these paintings for
himself after he had sold off most of
charles the first other great works
that's from rebecca
i think this is extremely interesting
because in a hampton court where uh
these paintings montana's trying the
caesars and now on have been for
generations
um is a real hot spot of imperial image
making and it's very very curious
imperial image making um
starting with henry viii and the
tapestries we mentioned but going
further
and
one of the things that charles the first
brought back
from
acquired let's say
from um the the gonzaga family in mantua
at the beginning of the 17th century
huge hall of works of art including
montana's
extraordinary set of canvases
of the triumphal procession of julius
caesar
and it's become very famous because it's
um
an extraordinary kind of recapturing
of what roman ceremonial looked like
based on clearly mantegna and looked
very hard
at
um
the images of roman victory processions
and i replicated them
and it's always taken
as a celebration of roman um of roman
success you know that the gonzaga and
mantion who commissioned it and then
charles the first who displayed it in
hampton court was wanting to show what
roman success looked like military
success
i've always thought that that missed the
point rather
because it certainly is that there's
certainly loads of um
of you know
ceremonial victory but the last canvas
is julius caesar looking very gaunt
actually a bit like the images that we
saw at the beginning
um in his triumphal chariot now
when you know bit of roman history
you think okay this is his triumph what
was the next big event in caesar's life
you know what well it was his
assassination you know he's months from
his assassination right and i think that
i i think in the recent book by stephen
campbell on montana it comes to the same
conclusion
um i i think that these are this is
deeply undercut this image of success
because all you have to do is to say and
what next
and all this panoply of ceremony and
success is undercut by what happens next
now
we do not know why oliver cromwell
decided not to flog these off
uh these paintings uh no idea you might
have been a fantastic admirer on the
choir montagna i doubt it
um
you know my suspicion is cromwell i'd
like to think that cromwell saw the
message in these paintings and that that
he knew
that what looked like a celebration of
autocracy and monarchy
was actually a terrible warning
about how it ended you know um
caesar and charles the first
sure comes to mind so
i in my fantasies though i couldn't
possibly tell you show you it was true
i think i think that cromwell
saw saw that there was a political
message
in his favor
in those paintings they you know as you
know all all celebrations of roman
military success are always undercut
actually yeah certainly
yeah
mary i uh we're looking at these
questions and i'm going to try and get
through at least one more
i i'm getting the sense that we we we
live in an age where we are as obsessed
with statues as the romans were this is
a question from inners hello mary thanks
so much for doing this such a big fan of
your work
why do you think the new statue of what
do you think of the new statue of mary
wollstonecraft by maggie hamlin does it
do her justice we're still obsessed with
statues we are we are i have to say i
much admire a lot of maggie hamlin's
work
and you can tell where this is going
um
i i
and i can see that this what this statue
of wollstonecraft is trying to do and i
can see this is trying to not represent
her as an individual you know it is
trying
to say there is more about women than
mary wollstonecraft
than there is about an individual um
and so for that reason i admire it do i
like it
um
um
i'm not sure i do
but i'm sort of pleased that it isn't a
kind of
representational image like what we've
just seen put up of lady die
you know
i think anything which helps us move
away from
um
a totally rigid way of seeing what a
statue of a human being is
helps us even if i don't particularly
like this one yeah
that's very politic if you may i i like
it well you should go and visit it
together and i will try and
treat you otherwise um
the last question um
well this is a nice question mary who's
your favorite who's your favorite caesar
of the twelve
i i think they're all absolutely awful
bastards
you know
you know would i like really to spend an
evening with any of them you know
you know well maybe an evening but
certainly not more
um
i'm
i'm curious
i mean i remain and this is what the
british museum exhibition at the moment
is playing into i'm curious about nero
um but i think that i'm very happy to
let my curiosity stay on the page
you know rather than know if anybody
ever says to me oh would you like to go
back and meet one of them you know
no you know
only if i've got a guaranteed day return
you know back to the ancient world
um you know and i think i think they're
interesting because of the way
they have represented the dilemmas of
power and they've continued to represent
the dilemmas of power right up to right
up to the 21st century and you know they
make us look at ourselves a bit harder
not just at them
yeah but you've certainly helped us to
look at ourselves a bit harder um and
it's been such an education um as ever
listening to you and reading the book
thank you so much mary beard and
congratulations on the new book um thank
you to our lovely audience who've asked
such learned and thoughtful questions um
it's been really um it's been so
intriguing while i'm running them over
with you and with mary and thank you to
intelligent squared for hosting this
event